welcome to part two of c plus plus
memory stuff
if you haven't watched the first episode
you probably should first if you're not
familiar with pointers at all but if you
already kind of are and just want to
see stuff about shared and unique
pointers then this is fine
this is fine let's talk about shared
pointers
and c plus plus so the whole point of a
shared pointer
is basically to manage your memory for
you
in general in this day and age with c
plus plus you should not be using
new and delete anymore shared and unique
pointers have
in general replaced all that and make it
a lot easier to work with
so yeah i said it all the stuff from the
first tutorial is basically useless
these days but i learned it when i
started learning c
spots before uh learning all these
shared pointers and stuff
so it's still good fundamental
foundational knowledge in the stuff you
see in a lot of code bases still
but anything new being coded up in 2020
and later is probably not going to be
using new and delete hardly at
all or any of that stuff except in
specific cases
you need to include the memory header or
using standard i o
just for print app and let's let's jump
into some examples
what is a shared pointer how do you use
it well in general you declare
a standard shared pointer and you give
it the type then you give your variable
name you don't have to assign it right
away but it often makes sense to
so the way you give it an initial value
an initial
declaration whatever
is you set it equal to make shared of
that type
and then whatever you want to initialize
with so floats can be initialized with
nothing it'll be set to zero or you can
give it a value here
of whatever you want to initialize it
with and this goes for any particular
object so you can make your own classes
make a shared pointer of your class
and use your initialization from your
constructors
there how do you work with this shared
pointer
you can think of a shared pointer as
just a pointer in most cases
but it has just a few special things
where let's look at this function
so i'm just you this is just a helper
function print shared pointer info and
we pass it stuff
as you can see it takes it by const
reference so it just has access to it
but can't change it and that's intended
because of course we're just going to do
some printing
so to get the value out of it you use a
star in front of it just like you would
with a normal pointer
and you can see what it its value is now
this works because the shared pointer
star is overloaded as you can see
my little pop up here on my ide it's
basically overloaded to spit out the
value on a float or the value of
whatever your class is so this may or
may not work depending on how your class
is built of course
and if you just want to get the raw
pointer you can use
dot get so you can uh this will get i'm
just going to show the address
here in that printout and you can see
how many other
pointers are referencing it because the
point of a shared pointer is
to be shareable so you can see how many
other
are holding a reference as uh the way
the shared pointer works is it deletes
itself
when there's no more use cases so
because of that it keeps track of its
use count and you can check at any time
how many things are using it
and when everyone's done with it it will
clean up after itself it'll call delete
on itself without you having to
specifically
manage it it's also this unique this
basically
returns true if there's one otherwise
false but you can see
the other things available to it by
using your intellisense or looking at
the header
i like to use the intellisense it makes
it easy so if you type in your shared
pointer
get your intellisense hotkey which is
control space by default i believe
you can see some stuff there's unique
use count owner before
and some operators to get to the data
let's run through all this
walk through all of it hopefully it all
makes sense i did build this other
function
just to grab it into another scope and
make an additional one
so you'll see that all right let's start
walking let's start
walking okay the part everybody loves
walking through the code
so this is the first print here is this
block
and we see that we initialize it to zero
so it shows the value of zero
shows the address there's the address
shows how many
are currently sharing it just one is it
unique true
because there's only one at this time so
let's look at where what happens before
we get to this next print we just assign
star stuff to 10. as you can see this
changes its value to
10 but doesn't change anything else then
we call stuff.reset
what does reset do well reset releases
the data basically it says this
sharepointer is no longer pointing at
anything
but right after that okay so i should
mention if you call this reset and then
you try to call a print on it it's going
to throw an error
so after the reset we can set it to a
new one
so that's sort of the point of reset and
then we'll get our info back out let me
go ahead and get this back up again
there we go we set it to 20 and we now
see that the value is 20.
and we see there's still only one
reference all right so we're going to
start making more references and play
around with that a little bit and see
what happens so we
declare another sharepointer called
other stuff and we'll set it equal to
stuff
so what happens here well essentially it
just makes a new one pointing to the
same data
so now it'll have two references and i
also decided to set the value
of the original one to one two three so
that you can see
that when you change the the value that
they're all pointing at
they all have that update because
they're all pointing to the same data
and all these shared pointers
that have the shared count or point at
the same data so when i print
for other stuff but i've changed the
value of the one and stuff the wealth is
about the same
so you see that it gets the value even
in
the other one it also says it's the same
address they're pointing to the same
address
and now it says shared count of two
because it has incremented
as it decided another one and none of
them have gone out of scope
now we go into another scope pass it in
the stuff
value create one in another scope print
it out and then leave
so here's what happens there we get to
that new one we print out the new one
after assigning it and our shared count
is three at that time
not unique and then we leave the
function so this other scope
goes out of scope and should reduce the
count again which we do see
now we'll call reset on this other stuff
that we created
as well so that basically gets rid of
its reference count without going out of
scope you can call reset and it gets rid
of it
as far as the reference count then we do
one last print on the original
and we see that there's now only one has
all these new values and it is unique
so that's in general kind of how you
play around with shared pointers
and how you can use them to share access
to a data and have it all be
automatically managed uh without having
to call new and delete
it'll just delete when there's no more
references so it is a data type that can
be
less code intensive and less brain
racking to try to keep track of all your
new and deletes you just share the
pointer as needed
when it's all done it cleans up after
itself it is actually quite nice
so is there a drawback well yes but it's
very small
and it's basically the size of these
shared pointers is like i think it's
double so it takes up a tiny bit more
memory
but the trade-off is pretty valuable in
my opinion
i like using shared pointers you know if
you have any questions down below about
shirt pointers and how to use them and
of course there is reference
documentation
if you want to read more about them now
let's try something
with unique pointer instead so unique
pointer
only allows one reference at a time
to control the memory and when it goes
out of scope or you reset it
the data gets deleted so unique pointer
is more for isolated control one thing
controls it at a time
so let's just do a thing where we rename
everything we've typed as
shared pointer to unique
pointer as you can see it doesn't like
this make shared anymore
naturally we have to use make unique
now and also you can see that it doesn't
like
some of these other things that shared
pointer offered like you can't just set
it equal to another one
that doesn't work you have to release
control from the original
if a new one is going to take control of
it so we can't there is no use count
anymore there is no unique
because it's always unique the use count
is always one
so what other options do we have let's
take a look by
checking with our intellisense and we
can see that there is
a lot less there's get which gets the
role pointer there's get deleter
as you can set up custom deleters for
your unique pointers
uh um yeah i guess i'll get into that a
little bit but that's
where it starts getting a little more
beyond beginner well we'll dig into it a
little anyway
here in a minute let's just delete those
we can see value
and address up admittedly there's a lot
to
these pointers that it's hard to show
everything in one quick example
but i'll try to at least give you the
main stuff and
you know if you want to dig in and read
more it's cool you can do that
so let's go ahead and run this and i'll
just walk through all this code and
hopefully
that is enough to make it a little more
uh transparent for most of you so
yeah unique pointers only one copy
allowed only one controller of the
memory so you gotta have ways to mess
with that
let's take it from the top here first we
make a unique pointer called
stuff and we just give it to the default
float constructor and then we check its
value so all this does is printed its
value and its address
of whatever that unique pointer is and
we do that by dereferencing on the value
and just getting the pointer to get the
address of it there
and we see right off the value 0 which
is expected and we have an address
that is some interesting bytecode and
then next thing we do is we assign
stuff to 10 so we can de-reference it to
do that
you can see it's an overloaded operator
on there for the unique pointer
and uh yeah there we go still same
address
new value and then we call reset
which will basically gets rid of
whatever was currently there and sets it
to
null so if we try to if we try to do a
print right after this reset we
throw an error because it's a null and
valid memory
so this reset will deconstruct it and
all that for you if you need to
but we're going to go ahead and reassign
it on the next line here with a new one
or just a new unique float of 20 and
then we print it and
as expected we get the value of 20 and
still the same address because it's
still
the same pointer it just is pointing to
new data since we reconstructed it and
now let's go to this next example
we create another one called other stuff
and
we're going to assign this we're going
to make a whole new one but we're going
to assign it
the value of stuff.release and then
we're going to dereference
that value because this release returns
a pointer to whatever the type is so it
releases
control of it so it will destruct and
de-allocate all the
original stuff but at return it's going
to end up returning a pointer and we're
going to dereference that pointer to get
the value
of what would be currently 20. so this
will ultimately just be 20 but also in
the process it is releasing
the old stuff so stuff is going to be
null after this
so we have this new other stuff anyway
we do a print after this just to check
the uh stuff that we released
and we'll just do a doing a boolean of a
get of the pointer
so that way we can see if it's null or
not if it's null
this will be false or zero which we see
here it is zero
so yeah it did indeed release it and
then we're going to go ahead and print
the info of this other stuff this one we
constructed and as expected is the value
20 but we do have a new address as we're
allocating a
new unique pointer so this old one is
just done
basically for now so we're going to go
to another scope right we're calling the
function
another scope and we're passing in this
other stuff pointer and we're going to
see what happens
so what this other another scope does is
it takes a reference to a
unique pointer and it basically
constructs a new one by moving the old
one into it so this
move semantic will actually destruct the
old one
so that's another interesting thing is
if you do a standard move
of a pointer to a new one you are
moving that data to the new one and the
old one is no longer
pointing to anything so since we're
doing this by reference we are literally
editing
this original pointer we're passing in
and then we're just doing a print info
this one we just created and as
we see now this is where it gets
interesting with this move and
we still have the value that's expected
but also we have the same address
on a different pointer and that's
because we did the move so
we just you know moved the it's it's
confusing a move
sounds like you would like you know
shift the data somewhere else
but actually it stays in the same place
it's more like it moves
this pointer and and or this new one to
the new space
uh it's just weird to have a function
called move that doesn't move or you
have to think of it backwards as it
moves
your pointer to where it is rather than
yeah
all right enough of that so as you can
see we have the same address and stuff
and now we'll go to down the last of it
we're just checking
if these are null or not so this other
stuff
is uh now that we have moved it
somewhere else
is now null as we see there and the
original stuff of course is null
and this one since it goes out of scope
right at the end of this function is
null and we actually have no unique
pointers allocated by the end of this
and here's the other example this is
basically
the en.cppreference.com
the unique pointer uh all the details
about it
it tells you all the stuff there's a
release there's reset there's what it
does
this is always a great place to go if
you're not sure about stuff or want to
learn more
about what these do and you also see it
as a get deleter
so you can assign functions to run your
deletion function by default just calls
delete
but you can make your own custom one if
you want to log or whatever or do
something special
and you're going to see that in this
example but anyway we can just run it in
their little online thing gcc something
apparently
they don't have the msvc1 in here which
is fine it should essentially do the
same thing
so i hit run on here and i got all this
stuff at the bottom
so we can kind of walk through this and
see what it's doing let's just start at
the top of the main
they've got all sorts of examples here
this might be a little long-winded
but it's going to be some great examples
of the things you can
do so first of all we just got the
standard c out unique ownership
semantics demo
oh auto p yeah that's another great
thing instead of
retyping this whole standard unique
pointer you can often just do auto and
it knows what you're doing because of
this make unique or that you're passing
it a unique pointer
so audio is super nice when you're
working with these pointers so the first
thing it does is uh
let's see it just makes a unique pointer
of this d class and this d
class where is it here it's okay so
we've got this initial
oh we're getting a little polymorphism
here too that's interesting
so yeah we got this virtual class here
this one was a bar unless you redefine
it with an override
so they've made a new struct and
inherited b and said hey we're going to
override
this bar function and say it's d bar so
that way you can tell which one you're
in
and the constructors just have a little
c out that says what you do so our
original c out is just this d thing
let's look down at the code and see what
we're doing we're doing a pass through
move for this auto queue uh where the
heck is that
so i feel like this is a really
confusing demo okay we're just calling
it directly in this pass through so
i'm passing this apparently you can do
my value or r value
they're just not even doing it by a
reference here which is interesting but
it's okay because it's only copying a
small
tiny pointer i believe anyway p
bar is what they call and that's where
we get this second one here
of it's saying bar and then we're
returning this pointer
they are doing a move so that's actually
a big deal
and that's this move is why they can do
it
uh by not reference because they're
literally saying this
is now that so basically
this q is going to become the new one
and
uh there it is so they're asserting that
uh
first of all that p is done because yeah
you moved the pointer out of it so it's
this one's done now at that point and
then they call the q bar which is
this right here now let's continue on
with that our main okay then they
deconstruct it which it shows right here
because they got a little c out
in that hope this is all making sense
but yeah it's just calling this one
at the end here so they're just messing
with our own little custom class
all right let's look at the runtime
polymorphism demo
so let's see if we can figure out what
all this does
first of all they're declaring a unique
pointer of this original class of
b which has two virtual functions and
they're making it a
a unique d which is something that
inherits it
and as you can see it constructs this d
class but uh what do we do next we
dispatch
this p bar we get the the d one and uh
let's see what other
cool stuff yeah this doesn't need to
have a little polymorphism standpoint
here uh they start messing with vectors
they say okay unique pointers can be
stored in a container like a vector a
vector of unique pointers for b
recalling the vector v and they're just
pushing back a brand new make unique
and as you can see it constructs it
right there and they're pushing back
a new one except this time they're
moving p as you can see
it does that and then then they're doing
it in place back which this one will
also construct a
new one well i think actually this one
right here doesn't construct a new one
it just moves one so it doesn't say
anything
this one here is gonna make a new d
which is gonna call that and then they
do this bar
three times go through each one of those
that they so that's going through all
three or three of those dispatching
uh whatever that and then it destructs
all three of them at the end because
they go out of scope
with this bracket so there's the three
destructions all right so next custom
deleter demo now they're doing it on a
file
i'll walk through all this and try to
make it make some sense
so custom deleter demo and they make a
new
output stream output file stream of
demo.txt
and they output the what an x so then
what they do is they make a unique
pointer the type is
file and their custom deleter is the
style type close
file reference now if we go look at this
close file all it is is a function
let's go find it close file there's the
function
it takes a file pointer and it just
calls close on the file pointer so
when it destructs it'll close the file
is the point so you can give
let's go find where we're at here we are
so
yeah you can uh you can give it a
function to run
you can do you can put lambda in here
you can make your own function
but apparently if you just made a
function you have to do this type in
reference thing to it
there's a ton of examples out there and
here we go and they call it
this unique pointer fp and they give it
uh this this f open and close file
as the uh that's the stuff to construct
it and then you just go to if
open basically do a standard c out get
care
and then when they do the uh c out of
the
get care fb get that's where this x
comes from
all right and then f close it should
close all that stuff
um let's see if close called here but
only a file is not null pointer because
that's what the function does
i believe yeah um that's a bit of a
harder one to understand
but it makes some sense okay let's look
at this custom lambda deleter demo
okay so we go to this unique pointer
type is d
and here's the function standard
function void
d star and there we go give it a new d
and here is the custom deleter starts a
lambda
capture this uh d pointer and called ptr
and then when this custom deleter runs
it'll say destroying from custom deleter
and then actually delete the pointer
and uh so we call p bar so we should get
okay so there's construction there's the
p uh
bar thing and then here's where the
destructor is called
is right there all right now array from
a unique pointer demo
all right let's look at this one so
we're uh okay this is a little different
this is
an array we're making a unique pointer
that is an array
we're giving it three little items there
so when it goes out of scope
it's gonna well it constructs three then
it deletes three so
you can put a raise in these unique
pointers too which is pretty interesting
and the link list demo looks like it
doesn't spit out anything here just
does something what are we doing here
link list for long and his giant number
l push and destroy all one million nodes
what
i'm not sure what the point of that
little demo is right there let's see
let's look at the list up here they have
some list thing here we go
okay so they're just using some unique
pointers
in a struct called a list that has nodes
and uh i guess it's a pretty standard
list thing i don't really want to walk
through this one they don't have a c
out to follow i feel like it's just
gonna make it confusing if i try to
walk through that one all right well i
think that's enough of this video
thanks for watching in the next video we
are gonna
probably looking at how unreal keeps uh
their life cycle of stuff we're gonna be
digging into their source code hopefully
hopefully it's open enough for me to be
able to do that but we're going to be
looking at some real world
cases of managing memory with c plus
thanks for watching
matt from code technotorials over and
pretty much out but before i am finally
out i'd like to give a shout out
to my patreon nassar howdy over
on patreon link down below if you'd like
to join he has made this episode
possible
if you like this sort of content please
don't forget to like and subscribe so
you can see when i come out with more
thanks for watching
peace out everyone
[Music]
you